new information on the death of Tyree
Nichols his family says that he died
after five Memphis police officers beat
him earlier this month an autopsy that
was requested by the family found
extensive bleeding caused by a severe
beating it did not list the cause of
death Lee's Preston asked the prosecutor
overseeing the investigation why police
body cam video has not been made public
we want to complete our key witness
interviews as soon as possible so if
we're going to be interviewing a suspect
for example in this case or any other
case
you don't want the suspect to be able to
see the video and then tailor their
statement to law enforcement to conform
to the video
a lot of people still want to hear the
video even though we hear it's terrible
to see the D.A plans to release it
within the next two weeks the officers
involved have been fired but they have
not been charged